-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night".
We hope you're doing well.
And now if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden spoke today
in Las Vegas about healthcare.
Oh, you mean that place where
everyone smokes indoors,
and it's cool to have
7 A.M. cocktails
as long as you haven't been
to sleep yet?
Yeah.
Sure healthcare in Vegas
is a major priority.
After Russian fighter jets
forced down
an unmanned Air Force
surveillance drone yesterday
over the Black Sea,
the White House said Russia's
actions were, quote, "Unsafe,
unprofessional, and reckless."
Well, yeah, I mean, it's Russia,
of course they're reckless.
They think the "Jackass" movies
are meditation videos.
After the U.S. drone
was forced down yesterday
by a Russian fighter jet,
Russia's ambassador to the U.S.
denied that
the two aircraft collided.
And Putin is claiming the drone
just fell out a window.
In a new interview,
former President Trump
said that his upcoming book,
"Letters to Trump",
will show readers that he has
had a, quote,
"very fascinating life".
Well, the fact that we have to
call that guy former president
shows that all of us have lived
a very fascinating life.
A student at
Princeton University
was arrested this week for his
alleged participation
in the Capitol attack, which
means even the Capitol Building
is easier to get into
than Harvard.
At a rally this week in Iowa,
former President Trump said that
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
reminds him
of Utah Senator Mitt Romney,
also Francis
from "Pee-wee's Big Adventure".
[ Laughter ]
A group of Senate Democrats
called on several retail chains,
including Costco, to sell
the abortion pill.
Though, I'm not sure that's
gonna work, because most people
would rather raise a child than
go to Costco on a Saturday.
According to a new survey,
people who live in rural areas
are more depressed, anxious,
and neurotic
than people who live in cities.
Sounds counterintuitive, but
then again, I've never seen
truck nuts on a yellow cab.
[ Laughter ]
Want to.
Taco Bell has announced
that next month,
it'll remove the Quesarito
from its menu in order to
bring back two popular items --
napkins and the bathroom code.
[ Laughter ]
And -- There was an "aw"
on the Quesarito comment.
Did you hear?
What a terrible -- You go to
a show, try to have a laugh,
and then you get terrible news
about the Quesarito.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, St. Patrick's Day
is two days away.
Well, you know what they say,
it's two days from now
somewhere!
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We've got a good show
for you tonight.